I do not think business people realize
that almost all the gold is in their
iPhone contacts from A to Z yes I could
tell you to start making unlimited tick
tocks in LinkedIn in seven months you'd
probably get inquiries or I could
literally ask you to make a video or six
so they're not all the same and be like
hey friend I'm actually texting this to
about 20 30 of my friends on my cell
phone to tell you like what I'm up to if
you give me three minutes just watch
this and you make like four different
versions homies kind of homies know them
pretty solid but haven't talked in a
year have no [__] idea who this is
and making four different videos and
literally for you it's like hey I'm just
doing business development hope you've
been well because remember the first 13
seconds for those four groups are going
to be very different the fourth one Hey
how
customers on my
shitty back with what you're up to maybe
I can help you just some Karma
that's gonna Land versus your first
group or to text and be like hey I made
this video for like my 25 closest
friends watch it